hi I'm David and I'm here to talk about
what we just talked about so the last
question just now was about hiring data
scientists how it's a challenge so even
when you have a data scientist what can
still be challenging there are many
problems or bad habits that help make
data scientist kind of unproductive so
this talk is about how we can you know
make them productive what are the
practices we can use to you know deliver
continuous deliver a male models
continuously safely and samely
so first we start with the why why we
need to change the way we work what's
wrong with the current workflows today
and what are some of the better
practices and how can we practice these
practices and so usually I the last time
I gave this talk at ex-cons I asked
people these questions but here today I
want to change the question a little bit
how many here are data engineers ok
about one-quarter of the room how many
here have developers ok how many are
data scientists ok panel you can hire
them there and how many are
non-technical folks ok cool so roughly
data engineers data developers right so
hopefully there's something for you to
take away as well
practices you can bring back to your
team and you know share your data
scientists and you know or even start
these kind of workflows in your projects
so what's the problem right one of these
things are not like the others so a car
a phone IKEA chair goes through
extensive testing use the testing before
it sees the users and safety and quality
is utmost priority
where's machine learning models you know
you can deploy it from your laptop
directly to production there's no way to
know when things are working there's no
way to know when things are breaking you
have to kind of hit it to know when
things are going wrong or right and so
this is not right because these machine
learning models are impacting people in
real life
sorry so it's just yeah I was a bit
distracted sorry so these people are
getting affected in real life let's
doing loans approval these loans are
getting denied because your mother said
no and things like that right so there
must be better ways for us to deliver
machine learning models where it's safe
and automated repeatable and deliver
continuous delivery practices help us to
change this so who here has heard of
continuous delivery okay so it's a set
of practices from the software
engineering world things like automated
testing continuous integration which we
will talk about and demo shortly that
helped us get fast feedback on our
software things that are going to
production how can we fail fast and fail
loudly so that we can you know prevent
bugs and things like that from going to
production so we are all kind of
familiar with this the Jupiter notebook
workflow there are scientists
happy writing code in Jupiter notebook
hashing out kind of quick and dirty
models I mean quick models and but
getting into production is hard right
yeah you might have experienced this
before so I won't go too much into it
and we want to change this is there a
better way for us to get into production
repeatably and reliably so we've got 99
problems but machine learning in one
machine learning typical is a very small
part of the code if you've done it
before it's like five lines of Python
code you can you know train a state of
the machine learning model but what's
hot is as we talked about in the panel
just now right getting data pipelines
for collecting data future engineering
you know sub deploying it and you know
getting the infrastructure to serve it
how do we monitor things when India in
production and most importantly kind of
potentially unethical side effects how
do we know things when things have gone
wrong right so today we will share some
of these practices that can help us
detect these things and the whole idea
of the talk is to help people do these
difficult things make it so easy that is
you don't forget it anymore
so if who here has heard of sorry for
the questions who here sort of create
react app okay so front-end developers
this this library called react maybe
three four years ago it was pretty hard
to use it because there's a lot of
configuration you got a thing about wet
pack and you know there's so much
configuration so it was hot so came
along this thing
create react that kind of takes care of
other configuration so we kind of the
inspiration for that and apply it from
machine learning we've created two
projects one is a ml CD starter kit
which is kind of like an infrared ball
will set up use kubernetes to set up an
infrastructure for you and we'll talk
about well show it later by essentially
an ml at template which is each machine
learning service or each app that you're
gonna create we kind of take away all
that configuration or at least kind of
have some sensible defaults so that you
can just start getting productive when
you when you start coding and then today
we share six common problems and
suggested solutions I will share the
link to these slides at the end so don't
worry about this okay let's go first
problem is the works on my machine
problem right so you've I'm sure you've
had this before you know you have data
scientists or friends who create all
these models and you know if they worked
on it for maybe days and weeks what's in
a notebook
finally they want to share this and now
you got a you know remember how I
installed the dependencies which
dependencies I install what Python
version and all that right so simply we
should not have this problem so from the
start just use some kind of
configuration management to docker works
really well for these kind of problems
so from the stuff I need data projects
let's just use a tool like this doesn't
have to be docker some you could learn
it so so okay but let's see let's see
how this works
so when we start I'm going to show a
video
right so to get started on any project
simply we should just get clone Dakka
Dakka run and get started to be
productive so this docker file we
install some OS level dependencies we
take a Python 3.6 base image we specify
all our dependencies in a file like all
other projects and there's the first
stage and the next thing that is more
long-running we retrain the model this
can take minutes or even hours so we do
it as a second stage in the docker file
okay so I've cloned this repo and in the
readme just build this image using that
docker file is a recipe and we're gonna
now start the container and immediately
your colleagues anyone will start being
productive it has all the dependencies
or the environments in everything in
this environment to start being
productive
so let's train the model now so where
there's a deep learning model or
whatever model doesn't matter all the
dependencies and then we can start being
productive so we start a simple flask
app for this and we'll make a prediction
just to see that it works yeah so you
don't need to spend a half a day a day
or a few days two of these I know my
songs you don't need so long to you know
get productive
and this should be the kind of a
sensible default in a in a project so
the next problem we face in data
projects is not having data don't need
to tell you this mmm interesting right
so just now in the panel again we talked
about you know when do we hire a data
scientist right okay we collect all the
data that we need actually in tall box
we think of a different approach we've
seen projects where we collect all the
data we need it may be you build a data
platform I didn't like something like
that
I've got months and maybe even a Europe
plus we don't know how we're gonna use
the data we have collected so much data
but it's not useful
so we invert this problem we have this
concept cut in sizing so we start with a
business problem we don't solve all the
problems in the world we just take a
domain say for example yeah whatever it
is and then we find a minimum viable
data set to solve that problem right we
start collecting a debt and do feature
engineering and strain a simple model
doesn't have to be a deep learning model
right off the bat and we try to solve
this problem and this helps us the risk
this data project this whole undertaking
and you know if this doesn't work if
this machine learning solution is not
off value to anyone they're fine we've
lost maybe a few weeks some a few months
of effort but it's not it helps us the
risk you know having years months and
years of collecting this data and find
that it's not useful so you know we try
to approach problems with a thin slicing
approach the next kind of mitigation
measure for this is to fake it till we
make it so Wizard of Oz on the outside
it looks like a wizard magic buy on the
inside is just a human so we can provide
the m/l like interface without the
implementation so for example a chatbot
right you can you don't need a recurrent
neural network right off the bat you can
start with rules regex
and this chatbot idea you can ship it to
production get feedback from your users
and maybe they find out at that point
oh hey chat bots are really useful and
push my user experience cool let's build
some of it alternatively maybe they say
hey this whole experience is really bad
you know I don't like this chat bot
thing yeah cool you don't you didn't
waste any effort collecting data
building machine learning models and
again you do risk this undertaking
and another benefit of this Wizard of Oz
approaches that we have a channel for
collecting data so these rules every
request every chat exchange you are
collecting data for your next real
machine learning model solution and I
will talk about this in a few slides
from now so just hold this tight for now
the next problem there we typically face
in Emma problems is deployments get
complicated so you know we don't ship
alena we ship maybe three four months
into the project and you know we have
this self-park problem where everything
is flaky and hot and brittle and now we
need to ship this thing off
so that's hot right so the mitigation
measure will suggest is to have
continuous integration we'll talk about
what that is and to deploy early and
often we don't deploy when we have some
finished product we deploy on week 1 of
the project ship something into
production of course you can have it not
launch people don't need to see this but
at least it's in production when you're
ready you release it right and with
often because with every comment you
want to just kind of keep shipping it to
the CI pipeline and run all the tests
and make sure you know everything is
always production ready ready to launch
at any time and the idea is to bring the
pain forward we can feel this pain in
you know four months five months down
the road and that would be incredibly
amount of pain right but when we bring
it earlier the complexity is less and
you find out using this technical tracer
bullet you trace this thing to
production you find out all the
integration issues in your s IT
environments in your production targets
whatever it is your constraints you find
that out you solve it early so then next
time deployment is simply a comment and
a push and it will be automatically
deploy and ready for production so let's
talk about what that looks like so this
is a typical CI pipeline continuous
integration pipeline the developer
pushes something to the source code and
it would trigger your CI pipeline first
thing we do is to run unit tests in any
machine learning project machine
learning is a small part a big part of
it is data processing data
transformation which engineering all of
these things are unit testable so we
don't want to wait you know
like three hours after the model is
trained student find out that oh you
know something is broken the F doesn't
work so we want to fail fast and fail
early so within seconds some minutes you
get feedback on whether this works so
alright we got this feedback unit tests
are failing we fix it now we push it we
fixed it now we go to the next stage
which is to train the model right this
can take again minutes and hours so fine
we just do it and usually your data
scientist has some way of evaluating a
model they use the eyeballs you some
metrics like R square RMS see something
like that there is some measure of a
goodness of a supervised learning model
and we basically are automating it and
put it in a CI pipeline and we'll show
you how that looks like and get feedback
so if let's say the accuracy is below
95% then break the build like this model
is not going off production 5% of the
time my clients who get wrong
predictions and that's not good enough
for me yes that's costly to me then I'll
break the build and make sure that this
bad model doesn't ever get to production
so let's say pass the test it's all good
we artifact it put it in some kind of
repository and we can deploy
automatically to some staging
environment and whenever you're ready
you click the button to deploy to
production and it's Auto Meter you'll
take a look at a demo later but this is
the rough idea of a CI pipeline they see
the idea is that every stage is a
quality gate as your model goes further
down the pipeline your quality your
confidence that it increases and yeah
yeah so that you know when somebody your
boss ask you okay are we good to go to
production this weekend okay yeah I
think we are we are our tests are
passing our models good enough we pass
all the other tests is offered certain
quality we can deploy it to production
so okay the demo will come later and the
next challenge we have is that okay we
got this CI pipeline we got all these
candidate models in production I'm sorry
all ready to go to production how do we
choose which one to go maybe there's
five models
candidate models maybe there's 100
candidate models how do we choose three
so typically again data scientists have
ways of measuring a goodness of a model
some kind
score accuracy or r-squared something
like that we are basically automating it
and automating the tracking of these
numbers so one such tool that helps us
with that is a 2-car ml flow my data
bricks and so you see here there's this
thing I love to call our square so a
square is a number between negative
infinity and one one being the best
liquor that's between zero and one zero
is crap and one is the best so just by
looking at this we know okay the first
tree are good better than the rest and
another error rmse this number the lower
the better
so okay immediately we know give given
that this model has been tested against
all of our evaluation data we know that
this candidate this comet char and this
particular model which has been at
affected is the best okay it's the least
incorrect we can shoot this to
production and you can have this
conversation with business and have
confidence to know that you know this is
the least damaging model and so we've
got to check this in our CI okay so now
imagine you have this CI pipeline is in
your project everything is awesome now
your boss comes around and ask you okay
cool
we deployed last Sunday how's it now how
many people are using it is it getting
the right answers is giving wrong
answers so these are hard questions
right we can answer it unless we observe
so there are three of three to four
benefits of observing and monitoring our
models I'll talk about each one of them
number one is a feedback on production
model so for example are there many the
several layers of monitoring and each of
them gives us are more and more value
number one is even just service usage
are people using our models the things
that we built for weeks and months if
nobody's using it then there's some
feedback to us right maybe our products
not right and that's good feedback to us
to pivot or do the right thing or talk
to users again and at the next level we
can also monitor model output so this
model is predicting housing prices in
thousands so right now is a number
between 10,000 and 40,000 if suddenly
your model starts rotating all you
or like I don't know two million
something then you know something's not
right
it's feedback to you that hey
something's going on in production
maybe that model is seeing they dyes
never seen before maybe there's some
typos you know we got to look into it
the next level is to monitor model
inputs some models learn from these
inputs and if we model each one of them
for example this one number of rooms
bitumens housing prices rate usually is
this number and if suddenly it shoots up
it's clearly this is gonna draw a model
off maybe you will maybe you won't but
at least now we know there's some
anomaly we can look into it this is what
we call in a machine learning the
problem of training serving skew which
is that your model performs really well
during training time but performs really
poorly during serving time it's a skew
between training and serving because
during serving time is seeing data that
it's never seen before the next benefit
of monitoring is interpretability right
so this is a problem machine learning
people complain that it's a black box in
order and yes certainly some models are
black boxes but some models can be
interpreted so for example this one for
each prediction it predicted that this
house is $34,000 $29,000 there are
libraries that help us decompose these
numbers output so for let's say this one
the number of rooms contribute at $6,000
to the price and this thing called else
debt you know maybe for this prediction
even reduced it by five five thousand
dollars so if your users complain to say
hey how come my house prediction price
is so low you have accountability you
can report back and you can also report
to your bosses about you know why the
model is performing a certain way or
it's because you know this feature is
you know pulling the data down whatever
it is so this gives us against feedback
into the model the next and I think the
most important feature or benefit of
monitoring is to close the data
collection loop so this is the CI
pipeline that you've seen earlier we got
some data we train and test we deploy
it's in production people using it so
every request we can log it
such-and-such housing in features I got
such a such a prediction this price this
now gives new new data for the
four more for subsequent training so in
machine learning that's the same garbage
in garbage ha
so the if you give you our model garbage
it's going to give you garbage so this
solves that problem you get better data
more real-world realistic data that can
train better models and the only thing
missing now is the ground truth right
what is the actual housing price that
this prediction should have been so
that's where you need a human in the
loop to do some data talking to apply
ground truth so that you can have more
training data for subsequent training a
more better more data is wins
sophisticated models hands down anytime
and the other benefit is that you now
have unseen data for which you can
evaluate your candidate models or your
production models so let's dive a little
bit deeper into this now this is again
the CI pipeline you push you build and
test evaluate model and now you can have
a second pipeline to say evaluate model
with new data
so this imagine an analogy like this one
is a student studying for an exam this
box here it's seen all the questions to
see not answers and this evaluate model
is it going for a mock exams right but
this evaluate model with new data is
going for the real exam that can be
trick questions that can be partial
information that can be all these things
and this will be the real measure of how
good this model is finally when we have
this score the goodness score of the
model we can decide to fill the bill or
pass the bill so so to speak and then
yeah we can have one glass look to say
okay each of these commits led to all
these models we can check it all the
time so I've said a lot of things and
yeah essentially we need to monitor
machine learning models and these are
the benefits we get so I thought about
how we can demo this thing so I think
it's useful to see how we can provision
all of these tools like goes just now we
talked about CI we talked about
monitoring how we can do this within I
don't know five minutes or ten minutes
in a you know project so we've created
this repo and this demo now will show
how we can provision go CD for your CI
ml flow for tracking hyperparameters
elasticsearch Cabana for
our monitoring and we will do this using
helm and kubernetes which is kubernetes
is basically a abstraction for you know
creating these different services for
deploying docker images and helm is a
tool to help you manage kubernetes
objects it's okay like don't get lost in
the details just this is just a quick
demo so let's take a look
okay so this is a two-minute video now
this is the ML CD starter kit let's
first create our infrastructure
so using GCP we can provision kubernetes
cluster if you have an on-prem thing you
can use cube APM to bootstrap kubernetes
cluster cool okay so now we got our VMs
where you can deploy our things we're
going to see that nothing is running
right now inside and we're gonna use
this toolkit helm to help us deploy what
we call charts basically your go CD or
an outflow all of these things and see
this right here
helm install is the staff the show you
will install all of the things that we
just talked about and I fast forward
this video I took about five minutes
when I recorded it to see ml Flo Cabana
elasticsearch all of these things come
up and these are the tools that you were
used to build your CI pipeline you're
monitoring your deployments things like
that so let's take a look at go CD
this is where your the tests will run
every time you come in and push it will
trigger some tests that we run here and
if it's it fails the test you get a
feedback straight away let's look at
Cubana which is a tool that lets you see
your locks so every request to your
housing price model you can view it here
you can visualize it as well to see
anomalies and lastly let's look at ml
flow which you can use to track hyper
parameters of your data scientists
experiments run now there's nothing so
let's run a training job our doing
locally but typically we do it this on
CI so locally I will run the train job
and whatever is the goodness score it
will log it to this ml flow service
okay I can see my name there the score
of my model and the hyperparameters are
used and every training run on CI will
be locked here so you have your
traceability and reproducibility I'm
also mindful of time I have four minutes
left so I unfortunately will have to
split through this pad so now we have
all of these things monitoring automated
deployments and everything it still does
not stop us from putting harmful models
into production these are actual news
headlines of AI gone wrong a predictive
post-listening algorithm it reinforces
racial biases recruiting - shows biases
against women this one AI cut somebody
healthcare and this teacher she's
creative and motivating but the AI said
she should be fired and she was actually
fired so the models can only learn from
data if the data is biased the model
will be biased okay so none of this CI
or monitoring nothing nothing was stop
it okay so what we need to do is to take
actual actions and mitigate this thing
so first of all we have to define and
discuss what bad looks like in our
context so for example if you are doing
housing loans denying somebody a loan
based on race if your mother that's that
clearly that would be a bad thing so we
have to have this conversation within
our teams and call that out and act on
it so one such exercise to help us get
there is what I call a black mirror
retro so you've seen that maybe you
heard of the show black mirror
it's like doomsday tech scenarios you
get a sticky in a sharpie and everybody
just lists down what could go wrong with
our model put it out there and we start
having this conversation right I'll skip
this part because it's a bit long to
explain data ethics there's a list link
that I put here it's very nice checklist
by this company called D on all the
ethical issues to look out for like for
example are we using PII data in our
training data are we do we have informed
consent when we collect this data so
this is a really good checklist I
encourage everybody to check it out and
now yeah and lastly I want to talk about
the ability to recover from home for
more
so suppose we have some shampoo model in
production is denying people loans based
on race so assuming this is something
that gone wrong usually doesn't happen
but the latest production deployment
just started doing this so when you do
CI and CD you get the ability to recover
from disasters like this for free to
decide to recover from this disaster we
simply roll back to the last good bill
so let's take a quick look what that
looks like so assume we have three two
deployments this first one is good that
one is bad okay this is what the good
model looks like just sends a hollow
whoa
this is why the bet deployment looks
like now we have a bad modern production
we got a recover from it
now because we because deployment 1 was
good we simply redeployed this thing and
we have again the exact model that was
good back into production and when I
recorded this it took two minutes to
redeploy it doesn't matter whether your
model is 10 megabytes 100 megabytes 2
gigabytes it will still take 2 minutes
because there's no rebuilding there is
no and there's no non-determinism
because we've artifact that each of
these models there's no chance that you
can rebuild a model that is bad because
we are not rebuilding anything when we
click that we're simply going back to
your docker registry to say okay take
this model to take this docker image
which has been certified good before
it's passed the whole CI pipeline is
been in production for some months or
weeks we know it's good ok put it back
into production so even if your model is
a deep learning model that takes hours
to train if one you don't have to wait
hours to recover from disaster if you do
see I like this is simply redeploying
the last good model so that's the last
thing I would say so okay well I'll I I
want to say one more thing so we shed
basically 6 ways 6 better ways of
working we've given you two repos that
you can check out so you can today go
home and run the comments and the readme
and do everything that I've just
you and start having better practices or
you know ci automated deployments
monitoring the only thing that we didn't
talk about here is how to write unit
tests that's really important and
unfortunately I don't have time to cover
it but you can Google online how do I
write unit tests and things like that
yeah so inside this ml CD starter kit
you will find basically how we can
provision and configure cross-cutting
services things that many ml services
will meet the shared services you can
get there and mi template use each ml
service itself unit tests boilerplate of
the trained model how to store your CI
pipeline is code how to track
hyperparameters and things like that so
we've gone from kind of wavy and unsure
path to production into a continuous
delivery cycle where we experiment and
develop locally with common and push you
automatically you automate it you do
automated testing automated deployments
automated monitoring and everything is
just before commit and a push so if you
are interested you can read more about
this you can also just search top waltz
CD for ml you'll find a nice article for
that so CD for ml you will find yeah
some more writing on this and that's it
thank you
[Applause]